the funny thing about feminism is that
so many people just don't see why we
need it imagine a social experiment one
that you should never ever do you have
identical twin boys and you call one out
and one Bob when they're five years old
you start giving them pocket money for
tidying away their toys every week you
give al a pound and Bob seventy eight
pence if Bob complains deny it
tell him he's imagining it if he shows
you evidence and insist that it's unfair
tell him al is just that little bit
better at helping out Bob will probably
start to get his shoes on faster and
tidy his toys like a boss to show that
he's as good as out occasionally when
bob has really excelled give him the
full pound and say see Bob this just
shows you can do it when you put the
work in you have to try a harder when
they're seven tell the twins it's time
one of them became the toy tidying
supervisor interviewed them both notice
that al comes to the interview with an
attitude like it's guarded in the bag
give the kid a high five and a fizzy
drink Bob will probably over explain
himself nervously in the interview do
nothing to relax him until he starts to
look defeated when you give al the job
congratulate him and tell him he's a
born leader
give Bob feedback that although he was
well-prepared and you appreciated his
PowerPoint presentation there was a
certain something missing tell him he
needs to be more like his brother but
he's lacking a certain confidence on
their 10th birthday asked the twins if
they'd like some pets when they
excitedly say yes introduce them to
fluffy and for loopy to adorable baby
hamsters and tell them they are the
absolute equal owners of the fluff balls
as they rush to stroke them explain that
Bob will have to do 90% of the feeding
grooming and
cleany Bob will ask how much he'll be
paid explained that hampster care is
worthless but needs to be done
relentlessly without pay
whenever you see al stroking the pence
say loudly to someone else isn't al a
great hamster daddy look at him
babysitting the hamsters and make sure
he hears it if Bob complains about the
extra workload or falls behind in his
toy tidying roll say well that's the
price for having it all Bob remember
you're the one who wanted the hamsters
let's roll out this experiment with a
whole generation of twin boys a few
Bob's will get angry and grow up to do
better than their brothers because they
have something to prove a small number
of Bob's will be gifted with so much
more natural smarts or talent that
they'll sail past their brothers
regardless as a trend though twenty
years from the beginning of this social
experiment twin boys called al will be
more confident greedy for leadership
roles sure of themselves and convinced
that their own opinions are facts then
their brothers called Bob it will be an
owl's world not a bob's world the funny
thing about feminism is that we can only
see how messed up that is when it's two
boys
you